it doesn't matter it wasn't like a
little like one white lie it was like
insane Brian Williams level was Jewish
too that was something else he said he
was he was Jewish he said he was the
producer of the Spider-Man Broadway show
he looks like somebody that tells like
the young twink person at a Broadway
show that he'll make their dreams come
true he just comes to his office for 15
minutes and it turns out that your dream
was not to be raped in George Santos's
office and then never get a role oh
no
look turns out that I made some promises
it turns out I was lying
it happens kiddo welcome to politics
kind of like what was this thing James
Franco that was just banging all those
chicks in NYU and by the way James
Franco never wrote the logos they try to
make something James Franco broke the
law but he just basically Banks some 18
19 year olds that were in acting school
and they just got mad that you know well
there was more to it than that because
there was a lot of those like uh where
some of the classes were like all right
today ladies all the lady uh actors are
gonna come in today and we're gonna
learn how to eat pineapple out of each
other's [__] it's method acting like
there was you know like Daniel Day-Lewis
I guess oh apparently Mercer's too good
for method actors oh I'm sorry have you
seen Gary Oldman they're like today but
it was also shitty like it was a shitty
like the teacher like the whole thing
was just set up to take these girls
money and like [__] them and stuff it
was kind of [__] up it was like all
right today we're gonna have World
acclaimed actress Ellen Barkin in to
teach you how to finger each other
slowly slowly and uh I'm gonna sit in
and watch it was like okay what are we
learning about acting here well yeah it
was a little predatory with James Franco
did yeah just act like you were molested
boom there's your story
I mean at least at least Harvey
Weinstein if he raped you you were
guaranteed an Oscar can I say that no
sentence should ever start with at least
Harvey Weinstein
like that's that I can't think of a
sentence where I just thought of one at
least he got you the Oscar
okay
Dan Schneider was raping kids and all
they got was a [__] Kids Choice Award
oh the Nickelodeon guy not the Redskins
guy yeah that's not gonna get you a
[__] uh character actor piece down
the road no Ariana Grande's doing great
though bro have you seen what Ariana
Grande looks like now okay
she looks just just pull up Ariana
Grande skinny she looks like she died
yeah it's really she looks really bad it
looks really bad
um she she like apparently oh she by the
way while he pulls it up she she came
out and she's saying I'm so sick of
people talking about my my weight I'm
actually very healthy it's like no one
that looks at her can possibly think
that she's healthy
just type like skinny [__] or whatever
it'll come up skinny [__] or whatever I
don't know bro I I found I mean it's up
there the problem is with Google it's
like also sanitized so they won't even
like rat out dude it's so bad now yeah
Google's all [__] up the image search
everything
yeah
that's right itself yeah there's one
yeah she is looking and that's not even
the worst one that's even that's worse
now her problem is she's gonna start
aging really badly because I mean yeah
because she's in Hollywood well no but
you have to have like fat deposits all
throughout your body to age gracefully
and he's like
there's all these women that get like
what's that called that bugle what's
that that the women are sucking the
there it is Buckle they're like sucking
it like out of their cheeks and [__] but
that's that looks so ladies that looks
so bad and again if you don't have at
least the basic fat deposits in your
face and you don't get the proper
nutrient like the Gwyneth paltrows all
look malnourished and Haggard and old
and it's like because you haven't you've
never eaten a piece of fruit in the last
like six months because you don't want
even the fruit sugar I did I eat
pineapple out of someone's ass because
James Franco told me to
Fair okay at least Harvey Weinstein
didn't give me [__] terrible snacks
see now I have one
um Ryan Harkness with the donation
Jennifer Lawrence has an Oscar okay
Harvey Weinstein is a [__] miracle
worker all right he is God on Earth
again
you can't say that Oscar that man
deserves to be freed on that Accolade
alone you guys are you know how many
strings he had to pull to get Jennifer
Lawrence an Oscar
and then she went and written and
flipped on him the nerve